françois fillon bonsoir on peut vraiment
s'attendre ce soir un dénouement positif
dans cette affaire en tout cas c'est un
signe très encourageant pour tous ceux
qui comme le gouvernement français comme
les gouvernements européens se battent
pour obtenir la libération de ces
malheureuses infirmière qui viennent de
connaître pendant huit ans un sort qui
ne peut laisser personne indifférent
à votre avis le déplacement libye il ya
quelques jours de cécilia sarkozy ça a
joué un rôle je pense que tous les
efforts engagés par les européens depuis
des mois et en particulier les efforts
très intense du gouvernement français
ont joué un rôle dans cette décision
positive et la visite du président de la
femme du président de la république ne
pouvait que marquer l'engagement total
de la france pour obtenir cette
libération
alors françois fillon vous retrouve dans
un instant pour parler de l'actualité
politique française avec jean michel
blier l'actualité politique aujourd'hui
c'était la présentation par rachida dati
à l'assemblée nationale du projet de loi
de lutte contre la récidive
le texte prévoit notamment
l'instauration de peines plancher est la
garde des sceaux faisait là son premier
discours à l'assemblée tunisair albert's
laurent feniou la parole et à madame la
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
le texte est controversé la ministre
attendu au tournant
mais rachida dati est mieux accueilli à
l'assemblée que lors de sa prestation
sénat la semaine dernière ce projet de
loi c'est autant sa vision de la justice
que celle de nicolas sarkozy commises
pour las pour elle
répression et prévention n'ont rien d'un
gros radis bhl ce texte est un texte
équilibré
on peut être ferme mais aussi et dans le
même temps juste et humain je veux pour
notre pays une justice sereine claires
compréhensibles par tous et d'égal accès
à tous l'arène parlementaire n'est pas
tendre avec la garde des sceaux
je vous en prie mais la majorité
présidentielle respectent la consigne
soutenir madame la ministre et son
projet de loi
je vous prie c'est un texte très grande
importance qui correspond à ce que les
français attendent sur lequel rachida a
fait un fantastique travail de
concertation d' écoute et je crois que
ça correspond vraiment à ce que les
français attendent dans ce projet de loi
trois grandes dispositions des peines
plancher pour les récidivistes dans le
cas de délit puni par plus de trois ans
de prison
la suppression de l'excusé de minorité
pour les 16 18 ans coupable d'atteintes
graves aux personnes d'agression
sexuelle enfin l'injonction de soins
pour les délinquants sexuels
pour l'opposition ce n'est qu'une loi de
plus tiens à vous dire que votre projet
sera au mieux inefficaces et au pire
dangereux
non seulement il va remplir des prisons
déjà surpeuplées et inhumaine mais en
plus lorsque les détenus vont ressortir
de prison ils vont sans doute récidive
est donc ce texte in fine et risque
d'aboutir au résultat contraire de celui
qui est affiché le projet de loi devrait
être votée jeudi par les députés est
définitivement adopté début août
la garde des sceaux s'attellera ensuite
à un autre gros dossier la rénovation du
système pénitentiaire
avec ce projet de loi la garde des
sceaux se retrouve plus que jamais
exposé malgré le soutien appuyé du
président de la république ou peut-être
à cause de lui la ministre fait face à
une série de critiques et d'attac
dernier épisode en date la révélation
des déboires judiciaires d'un de ses
frères qui comparaissaient justement
aujourd'hui pour trafic de stupéfiants
patrice machuret stéphane taponier on ne
choisit ni sa famille ni le jour de son
procès pendant que sa soeur rachida
faisait face aux députés son frère
récidiviste jamal dati affrontaient les
juges de la cour d'appel de nancy pour
trafic de stupéfiants
honnêtement je le regrette j'ai un
boulot mon boulot mon entreprise
elle-même même l'a bien aidé je me suis
sorti tout ça voilà aujourd'hui nous en
aurons d'une affaire du siècle alors que
c'est un mauvais passage dans ma vie
c'est tout j'ai tout fait pour m'en
sortir
et le résultat est là
parmi les douze enfants dati un autre
frère omar est mis en cause dans une
affaire similaire une situation délicate
pour la ministre de la justice dans
toutes les familles il ya des moments
difficiles
les histoires difficiles et des filières
vos frères et des étapes difficiles j'en
dirai pas plus je ferai pas de
commentaire il serait malvenu en tant
que garde des sceaux de faire les
commentaires et par pudeur je n'irai pas
plus loin
fille de maçon marocain rachida dati
s'est sorti seul de sa cité hlm
elle en a gardé un caractère trempé qui
a séduit nicolas sarkozy mais pas son
directeur de cabinet qui a démissionné
la semaine dernière avec trois
conseillers l'ancienne magistrate
traverse une passe difficile et le
couple présidentiel dont elle est proche
ne cesse de la conforter la présence de
rachida place vendôme c'est un message
adressé à tous les enfants de france que
pour chacun passe on mérite par son
effort par son engagement
ça devient possible pour sos racisme
la ministre est victime de ses origines
maghrébines une opinion partagée par
bazire a qui arrivent opposante
socialiste mais femmes solidaires finale
quitte à la croisée des tirs de ceux qui
premièrement on l'imaginaire colonial
encore prégnant et qui ne veulent pas
voir que qui veulent voir que l'immigré
comme alphabètes certainement pas comme
sénateur ou c'est vraiment pas qu'on
garde des sceaux premier point deuxième
point il y à aussi ceux qui sont de la
diversité qui considère que parce
qu'elle est à droite c'est de la
trahison
depuis sa nomination rachida dati
applique la même méthode que son mentor
occuper le terrain se montrait au
maximum une surexposition sans doute
dangereuse ans sa fille on a
l'impression que rachida dati victime
d'une campagne de déstabilisation à
votre avis quelles sont les raisons
témoin je suis très fier avec nicolas
sarkozy de l'avoir nommé au ministère de
la justice et je vais dire qu'en deux
mois et s'est révélée elle a engagé une
réforme
qui est en cours de discussion à
l'assemblée nationale très très
importante sur la récidive réforme qui
est déjà passé au sénat en une journée
elle a engagé un débat très très
difficile sur la réforme de la carte
judiciaire pour moderniser la justice
alors elle est exigeante avec ses
collaborateurs ça tombe bien parce que
le président de la république et moi on
est exigeant avec nos ministres c'est
vrai que je suis choqué par la campagne
qui est engagée contre elle c'est la
première fois que je vois que la
composition d'un cabinet ministériel
devient une affaire d'état
moi je veux qu'on traite rachida dati
comme n'importe quel autre ministre de
la république et je suis sûr que si elle
est traitée comme n'importe quel autre
mise de la république
elle va montrer avec beaucoup
d'efficacité sans talons à propos du
texte de loin du projet sur la récidive
les magistrats estiment que le problème
au fond le plus urgent c'est peut-être
plus tôt les délais il n'y a pas selon
assez de fonctionnaires pour que la
sanction interviennent plus vite tout de
suite après une infraction
il est difficile de contester qu' il
soit normal de punir plus sévèrement
quelqu'un qui commet plusieurs fois la
même faute
on sait d'ailleurs que dans notre
société ce sont quelques milliers
d'individus qui commettent la grande
majorité des délits qui empoisonnent la
vie des français et quand on dit les
magistrats sont des organisations
représentatives de certains magistrats
qui contestent pas tous les magistrats
qui sur le terrain voit bien la
nécessité de durcir les sanctions - ce
qui m'obsède c'est la sécurité des
français
s'il faut construire des prisons
construire des prisons s'il faut c'est
ce qu'ont fait d'ailleurs choisir
d'autres manières de faire purger un
certain nombre de délinquants leur peine
pour justement faire des places dans les
prisons pour ceux qui sont les plus
dangereux et qui ceux qui ont plus
besoin d'être sanctionné on le fera mais
la sanction c'est quand même la base de
la sagesse et de l'interdiction de la
récidive
un magistrat cité cet exemple ce matin
un jeune qui volent pour la deuxième
fois un dvd dans un supermarché risquera
avec la nouvelle loi un an de prison
c'est complètement faux pas ce que sont
les juges de toute façon qu'il garde
l'entière maîtrise de la
de la peine est donc cet exemple est un
exemple qui est fait pour
disqualifié un texte qui est un texte
qu'il n'a rien à voir avec cela
sont les juges qui gardent la maîtrise
des décisions simplement la loi oblige à
un traitement plus sévères pour les
récidivistes
pas forcément un an de prison pour
quelqu'un qui a volé un dvd deux fois
alors il ya un autre projet de loi qui
fait débat c'est celui sur le service
minimum
les syndicats crient à l'atteinte au
droit de grève
est ce qu'au fond secte ce projet de loi
était utile quand c'est que dans les
entreprises où on a mis en place un
dispositif d alarme sociale comme à la
ratp par exemple et bien le taux de
grève a fortement diminué ces dernières
années
ça fait dix ans que régulièrement tous
les sondages montrent que 70 à 80 % des
français sont exaspérés par les
interruptions des services de transport
aux heures de pointe
nous avons donc voulu répondre à cette
question et nous avons voulu le faire de
la manière la plus ouverte possible
c'est à dire en faisant confiance au
dialogue social
le texte que nous proposons il dit quoi
il y met d'abord en place des systèmes
de prévention il généralise les systèmes
de prévention des conflits qui avait été
testé par certaines entreprises
deuxièmement y confie aux organisations
aux heures aux organismes qui structure
qui organise les services de transports
ou aux entreprises le soin de fixer un
service minimum adaptée à chaque
situation et enfin il met en place des
contraintes en particulier l'obligation
pour tous les salariés qui décident de
faire grève de le déclarer 48 heures à
l'avancé pour que l'entreprise aux
secours que l'entreprise va gagner le
service est ce qu'il risque d'y avoir
des pressions sur les salariés qui
souhaitent légitimement faire grève
viendra pas de pression plus qu' il n'y
en a aujourd'hui je crois que c'est pas
vraiment le sujet le sujet c'est simple
le droit de grève est un droit
fondamental le droit d'aller travailler
aussi et
les salariés de ces entreprises de
transport ne peuvent pas ne pas voir
cette exigence que les français ont
manifesté à maintes reprises qu'ils ont
encore manifesté à l'occasion des
élections présidentielles il faut il
faut il faut du dialogue social c'est on
mise sur le dialogue social pour réussir
mais en même temps il faut que les
choses soient claires le droit de grève
et garantit le droit d'aller travailler
aussi en même temps qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui craignent que ça ne
soit un cheval de troie et que ce
service minimum soit après les
transports étendue à d'autres domaines
par exemple l'éducation nationale à
écouter si ça marche vois pas pourquoi
on étendrait pas à d'autres domaines
parce que l'objectif c'est quand même
bien de fournir en permanence le
meilleur service public à tous les
français et je voudrais pas qu'on perde
de vue cet objectif là bien sûr le droit
de grève doit être protégé il ya
d'ailleurs beaucoup de services publics
où cette question a été résolue
parfaitement on envisagerait pas
d'interrompre l'activité d'un hôpital
même lorsqu'un nationale ça pourrait
être un gage et moi je pense que là la
démonstration qui sera faite de
l'efficacité du dialogue social dans les
transports peut ensuite servir de modèle
pour être étendu dans d'autres secteurs
dont l'éducation nationale alors on va
passer à un autre
hier soir les députés ont adopté en
première lecture le paquet fiscal il
devrait coûter environ 13 milliards
d'euros ça va creuser les déficits
c'est un pari risqué sur l'avenir alors
je crois pas du tout que ça va creuser
les déficits et c'est pas un paquet
fiscal c'est un projet de loi qui vise à
favoriser la récompense du mérite du
travail et de l'effort
c'est un peu une révolution culturelle
pendant des années on a dit aux français
il faut travailler moins parce que si
vous travaillez moins y aura plus de
travail pour les français
on a vu que c'était un échec que la
france était un des pays qui a vu le
taux de chômage le plus élevé et donc on
a décidé de rompre avec cette tradition
avec ses erreurs qui nous ont conduits
là où nous sommes ce que nous voulons
c'est que et c'est l'essentiel du projet
de loi
tous ceux qui veulent travailler plus
faire des heures supplémentaires
puissent le faire et puissent le faire
en étant en gagnant vraiment plus c'est
à dire en ne payant pas d'impôts en ne
payant pas de charges sur les heures
supplémentaires
mais qu'est-ce qui est ce qui vous fait
penser qu' on va sortir de cette
croissance molle que l'on connaît depuis
plusieurs dizaines d'années je dirais
que vous allez avoir ce bonus 1% de
croissance supplémentaire parce que nous
changeons totalement d'état d'esprit
on va encourager le travail on encourage
les gens qui ont réussi dans la vie à
investir dans les entreprises alors
qu'avant les encourager à quitter le
pays pour aller investir dans les
entreprises étrangères
on va continuer d'ailleurs cet effort en
faveur de la croissance au à l'automne
en mettant en place toute une série de
dispositions pour lever les contraintes
qui pèsent sur les entreprises
françaises par rapport aux entreprises
européennes
je crois que le coeur le moteur de la
croissance que nous voulons retrouver
c'est le sentiment que les français
auront que s'ils travaillent s'ils font
des heures supplémentaires six économies
s'ils investissent ils sont récompensés
pour ceux qui font ce qui n'était pas le
cas aujourd'hui ça me permet peut-être
de dire un mot sur les infirmières parce
que je vois depuis quelques jours
beaucoup de sujets sur les infirmières
qui font des heures supplémentaires et
qui ne sont pas payés mais je dis que
nous nous sommes scandalisés président
de la république et moi même par le fait
qu'il puisse y avoir dans notre pays des
gens qui font des heures supplémentaires
qui ne soient pas payés et donc j'ai
demandé aux ministres compétents de
mettre en oeuvre tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour que ces heures
supplémentaires soit juste un mot à ce
propos il ya des à l'hôpital des comptes
épargne temps qui se sont générés à
cause des 35 heures est ce que vous
seriez prêt à payer une partie de ses
comptes épargne alors d'abord ses
comptes épargne temps sont garantis je
veux dire que les dispositions ont été
prises pour qu'ils soient financés mais
au delà je souhaite qu'on puisse si on
le sien si on désire faire des heures
supplémentaires à l'hôpital ou si on a
fait des heures supplémentaires à
l'hôpital être rémunéré c'est normal
enfin quelle est cette société peut
fonctionner dans un système où celui qui
travaille plus ne gagne pas plus merci
monsieur le premier ministre d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation